foreign
Star Wars has been at The Cutting Edge
of special effects puppets Prosthetics
animatronics CGI and now thankfully
animatronics again well the facial
expressions goal or the limbs move in
it's almost like a little symphony you
know it all comes together in a very
magical moment
create the Star Wars world we have to
create monsters that inhabit these
strange alien worlds
Gustav's been making monsters for three
decades and he's taking a look back at
his Creations I made many creatures
Royal redis Six eyes l-o-s-d Admiral
Akbar the head of Mars take us back to
the beginning where did it all start I
remember vividly my dad taking me to see
Return of the Jedi in tashinsky cinema
in Amsterdam when I was six years old
that film sort of lit a spark in me
first of all I was just in all
overwhelmed and it made me extremely
curious how they crafted these films how
they can physically make something that
realistic I just took it all in and I
think that sort of you know slowly
prepared me for my future career I would
read up on books magazines I started
experimenting with rubber heads hobby
clay plaster wood anything and put him
in my rumors ornaments you know I just
kept churning him out trying to perfect
my style so how does it work it's a
lengthy process from scripts it goes to
the design department and then that mold
lands on my desk I insert clay for the
for to create the Skin Within that I
build my animatronics
every hair has to be perfect the
movement has to be near perfect you can
only get do so much with the rubber skin
that sounds like a lot when I take a
creature on set my anxiety levels are
through the roof just because I know
what potentially could go wrong and how
much is riding on it so I'm just hoping
it's good and it goes beyond Star Wars
hitchhikers that did jelts
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory I did
the squirrels that listen to nuts and
they asked me to build a swimming Oompa
Loompa I remember not being able to
sleep because I was so nervous because
mechanics electronics and water don't
mix did it work out okay the moment
comes that we're shooting it to burn
says action the kids run in run to the
tank
and they say yep release the Oompa
Loompa switch it on swim through frame
he says cut we got it that was one of
their moments that I felt like I was
walking on an air Gustav's done his fair
share of creepy Horrors too there was
this small finished film I did and the
creature we built that was very
prominent in the film it was like almost
like a throwback to the 80s you know
we're on the floor with rods and doing
everything in our power to bring this
thing to life the blinks are still
linked up tomorrow you can hear the
buzzing noise
it was a mechanical jaw and a mechanical
tunnel which was a nice little extra
so after 30 years in the job what's the
secret it's all about replicating the
organic movements that you see in nature
that's the art of animatronics it's
breathing life into a rubber skin to see
one of your Creations on a big screen
that's what you do it for
[Music]